hey-ya doing good I came here to give
you a science lesson about animal mating
systems and why defining monogamy has
been a challenge for scientists but you
won't need a textbook or download an
online lecture all you'll simply need to
do is revisit the song OPP by Naughty by
Nature it was released in 1991
now OPP is a call-and-response song so
throughout the top I'm gonna put lyrics
up on the screen and I'm gonna recite
some and I'm gonna prompt you when it's
your turn to do the response ok now I
know some people in this audience know
this song so I need you to lead the way
with the tempo and the rhythm if that's
alright ok alright y'all ready you know
what else that was perfect
Thank You OPP I can't explain it I take
your frame by frame it to have y'all
jump and shout and singing it always for
other P is for people scratchy temple
the last P will that's not that simple
now in the song the MC hints that it's a
five letter word but to keep it rated PG
he simply refers to it as property the
song is about cheating on your
significant other now around the time
that this song was in heavy rotation
biologists were in deep discussion about
whether bird species notably songbirds
and waterfowl were actually monogamous
or not see for decades generations of
science students were taught that well
over 90 percent of the bird species were
monogamous a male and female mating
faithfully for life that was until the
late 1980s when a new laboratory
technique came on the scene which could
copy DNA from a small tissue or fluid
sample and decode the genetics of
individuals now before that technique we
were never ever certain about
100% who the parents of baby birds were
all we had where I feel notes and we
would know which adults lived in the
nest and which ones fed the baby birds
well come to find out
study after study kept coming in and we
found so much evidence of infidelity
among bird species particularly these
songbirds that we thought were the
pinnacle of monogamy it would have made
Maury Povich jealous for the ratings it
rocked biology in ornithology so hard we
had to modify and expand the entire
definition of monogamy now it was so bad
that this was the headline of the New
York Times science section August 1990
mating for life is not for the birds or
bees we had to come up with new
definitions the situation aware a
individual will change partners either
between breeding seasons or just simply
because they didn't like their partner
anymore we now call this serial monogamy
I didn't know it's gonna be this funny
the situation where we well we know the
male and female pair together and all
the babies belong to both partners we
call that genetic monogamy and we now
recognize that it only holds true for
about 14% of the songbird species we
thought word we were very certain with
truly monogamous and with this
reclassification realized that in a lot
of those field observations where we saw
a male and female sharing a nest cold
maintaining a territory even
provisioning offspring together often
included a few baby birds that did not
belong to the male partner we call this
social monogamy
and the mechanism responsible extra pair
copulation its OPP time for other
people's what you get it there's no one
for a relationship there's just room to
how many brothers out there know just
what I'm getting that who think is wrong
cuz I was splitting and co hit net well
if you do that's OPP actually that's EPC
which is the abbreviation for extra pair
copulation
now we define extra pair copulation is
the mating outside of a pair bond and
just like we were discovering the Esaias
it can lead to babies that don't belong
to the male partner
alright now I first learned about you
pcs years later after all the science
news broke while I was in graduate
school and as we were taking a class
talking about current discoveries and
mating systems this topic comes up and
as my professor is going through the
definition and recounting all the
dramatic turn of events that lead to
these new revelations I'm sitting in
class and a familiar song stars popping
in my head I'm right you know I mean
that's exactly what that song was about
EP sees and what I recognize is that
this gives us an opportunity to revisit
this song let's let's switch the lyrics
up so say EPC say it like even it's an
EPC I like to stay with pride now when
you do it do it well and make sure that
it counts you're not down with a
discount you know a TCC and you know you
know what ECC
now I have always been playing songs in
my head while I was in science class
kind of tapping into this index of pop
culture and hip-hop songs but when I
would share my analogies with my science
professors all of whom are older white
men I often got blank and confused
stares as responses but when I would
share this with people from communities
like mine or other colleagues so diverse
communities this hip-hop science remix
was a hit that's because I was either
talking to people who looked and sounded
like me but at the very least you know
listened to some of the same songs we
were sharing a common cultural lexicon
and with that Mexican I was able to
bring new science terms to them and
together we were sharing a new
comprehension of science for the culture
now hip hop in hip hop song references
are a really good tool for teaching
content to students from hip-hop culture
or urban communities and I use it
intentionally to connect to those
students tapping into vocabulary that
they already know and systems that they
already comprehend and what it does in
that process is it ratifies them us our
culture is knowledge purveyors I use
hip-hop to frame and communicate science
because I'm intentionally communicating
science to broader audiences that public
science outreach has traditionally
overlooked and in the process I am
affirming the genius that thrives in the
young minds of people from every hood
everywhere so let me ask you one last
time you know an EVC you know ABC
you know any PC what's that woody TC
thank you